foreign
cinematographers can communicate so much
to an audience with even the subtlest
elements of how they can pose a shot yes
I'm talking about burning again in the
movie zhangsu is enjoying the time he's
getting to spend with hey me who's just
reconnected with
hunger
in this scene they eat together and we
get a fairly standard series of shot
reverse shots with mediums and close-ups
it feels pretty intimate and like
they're just spending time together the
two of them but then in the story Ben
shows up and zhangsu is competing with
him for Jaime's attention now watch this
scene where they're at dinner together
and Jaime and zhangsu are talking and
Ben is just kind of listening he's not
even really part of the conversation
right now
foreign
foreign
but look at how this conversation is
framed compared to the previous one in
this two shot which is where most of
this moment happens it's wider it
includes both of them and it's framed
with a subtle imbalance to the right
side of hey me even though Ben isn't
part of the conversation at this point
and the moment is mostly happening
between xiangsu and hey me framing the
moment from this angle subtly keeps
Ben's presence in our attention and
makes the whole thing feel less intimate
between xiangsu and hey me at this point
in the story zhangsu's Focus has kind of
shifted from hey me to a preoccupation
with the status of the three of them and
the compositions from this point on in
the film subtly reflect that check out
this scene where zhangsu comes into this
coffee shop and thinks for a moment that
he has hey me to himself and then
surprise there's Ben in the background
literally Loom zooming over the two of
them this video is sponsored by mubi get
your extended 30-day free trial today
most of the discussions and awards
surrounding cinematography focus on this
kind of thing stunning films with bold
striking use of camera movement
composition and lighting I think there's
often kind of a conflation between good
cinematography and beautiful images now
like with my video about subtle acting I
want to be clear I don't think there's
anything wrong with this kind of
cinematography creating beautiful images
can be such an important part of making
beautiful films and creating great
cinematography that leaves an impression
on people beautiful cinematography can
draw you into the story and make it even
more impactful two of my favorite
directors are Terence Malek and Wes
Anderson in part because of the way they
use beautiful images in their films it
would be hard to describe Emmanuel
lubeski's work with Malik as anything
close to subtle but I think the two of
them together have created some of the
most profound iconic images that have
come out of Cinema in the last decade so
all that to say there's nothing wrong
with this kind of cinematography but if
we reduce the discussion around what
great cinematography is down simply to
beautiful images I think it's incredibly
reductive and in doing that I think we
can miss out on many of the subtler ways
that cinematography can be an incredibly
powerful tool to communicate meaning in
film so let's highlight some of the
moments where the cinematography might
not be as attention grabbing or visually
stunning but is still doing a lot of
work to convey the meaning of the film
when I talk about subtle cinematography
I don't just mean minimalistic
cinematography although I do think there
is a lot of more minimalist
cinematography that gets overlooked even
though it's no less impactful at
conveying meaning simply because it's
less showy Joanna Hogs the souvenir is
one of my favorite films recently and I
think it's an incredible example of more
minimalistic cinematography done
incredibly well the film charts a
relationship between Julie and Anthony
and as the film opens them are
introduced to Julie's life we get this
wonderful free handheld camera work but
then look at what happens when Julie
goes on her first date with Anthony
suddenly the camera is locked down in
position and it basically stays this way
for much of the rest of the film it's a
beautiful evocative way of communicating
that this relationship has caused a
shift in Julie's life and you might
think that locking a camera down onto a
tripod might limit the expressiveness
but you can do so much just through
composition look at this scene where
there's a pivotal Revelation about the
relationship which I won't spoil
see how this conversation is framed in a
fairly standard way and then look at how
suddenly it goes off kilter and then
crosses the 180 degree Rule and switches
to a much more distinct framing that
separates Julie over here and almost
causes this dissociative effect in the
conversation it looks as if she's
separated from what's Happening almost
observing the conversation from a
distance and then there's this other
beautiful subtle moment watch as Anthony
returns to the table and his shadow
briefly passes over Julie's face it's
like a literal representation of the
shadow that this moment is casting on
her
Reuben oslin's Force measure is another
great example of doing a lot with a
fairly minimalistic approach to
cinematography
the film opens with this family on a ski
vacation and they're all having a pretty
good happy time and we get these shots
where all of them are included together
in the frame but then watch what happens
to the compositions after there's an
incident that causes a rift between the
husband and wife through a combination
of composition and blocking we begin to
see how things are literally fracturing
and a divide is created between the
husband and wife there's a great
sequence where another couple comes to
visit this husband and wife and the
husband and wife talk about their
argument which literally causes a rift
then between the visiting couple the
composition and blocking of this scene
illustrates how that's happening
perfectly
this is one movie that had the
misfortune of getting an American remake
and one of the things that the English
language version does besides just suck
a lot of the subtlety out of the writing
is remove this element of composition
and cinematography and entirely from how
the story is conveyed and the American
version is just so much more flat and
empty because of it one director whose
career I think is an excellent
illustration of kind of the range of
what can constitute great cinematography
is Paul Thomas Anderson when you say
Paul Thomas Anderson in cinematography
you probably immediately think of his
oscar-winning work with Robert elswit on
There Will Be Blood or the really
energetic evocative work of Boogie
Nights or the long tracking shots we
find in Magnolia those movies have
incredible cinematography but just as
impressive to me is a lot of his later
work like inherent Vice and Phantom
thread in these films there aren't these
iconic images or moments that stick in
my mind but what is just as impactful is
the way these movies feel Phantom thread
isn't one of these movies that comes at
you with these striking images instead
it's more of a soft mood and vibe that
just kind of saturates the entire film
and that's not an accident at all it's
very deliberate and constructed the
subdued colors and the softness of the
highlights are created by the choice of
film stock and the filters placed in
front of the lens there's a BTS video
that shows some of the test footage they
shot
[Applause]
and you can see how much work went into
just choosing the right filters for the
lens and film stock for this film and
those elements match tonally with the
performances and story that the film is
telling these are the smaller details of
cinematography that don't usually get
talked about outside of the more
technical discussions but these choices
can have a huge impact on how the final
film feels PTA does the same thing in
the master inherent Vice and licorice
pizza each of these movies have their
own look that is distinct from the other
but which feels completely appropriate
to the story each film is telling of
course what constitutes subtle is
culturally and personally subjective I
kind of doubt that masaki kobayashi's
harakiri was perceived as subtle when it
was released in 1962 but when you
compare it to some of the stuff that
we're used to now
it's essentially a master class in
Restraint there's a lot of bold striking
images in this film but what I want to
focus on is not just movies that have
subtle cinematography overall but how
subtler elements of cinematography that
we're less likely to notice can still
convey meaning one of the ways Kobayashi
does that in this film is by changing
the cinematographic style based on what
he's trying to represent when he's
establishing this very traditional
orderly and almost tyrannical Samurai
Clan at the beginning of the film he
uses very precise compositions that have
very little movement but then when he's
introducing a character that is
challenging some of that tradition he
uses camera movements that at that time
would have been more bold and
challenging to traditions of filmmaking
these shifts in stylistic approach to
convey meaning is one of my favorite
tools that cinematographers can use and
I think it's one of the subtler ways
that profound meaning can be
communicated in a way that might kind of
fly under the radar for viewers at least
on a first watch sometimes the shift
isn't in the stylistic approach so much
as the perspective from which things are
shot in my first ever video for this
channel I talked about how in
Nightcrawler director Dan Gilroy and
cinematographer Robert Ellsworth shift
the perspective over the course of the
film from one where we're watching Luke
Bloom from a detached perspective film
these crime scenes and disasters in a
predatory way to a perspective where
we're actually seeing what he's filming
and watching what he's filming
implicating us as the viewers in this
toxic ecosystem of media one of the most
beautiful shows on television right now
from a cinematography perspective is
Euphoria and I made a video talking
about how I think that show fits within
a lineage of expressionism in
cinematography one of the oldest and
boldest stylistic approaches to
cinematography but you don't have to
harness expressionism for your entire
film or show I love when filmmakers know
how to add just a dash in the right
moment such a jit Rey does this in his
incredible the big city the film is shot
beautifully and naturalistically
throughout but in this one moment eradi
is facing kind of the anxiety and
turmoil of her Newfound freedom and he
portrays that conflict beautifully with
the expressionistic lines and
composition behind her in this shot
there are so many great examples of this
kind of subtle cinematography I could
show again this kind of list isn't meant
to be the best examples or you know a
definitive list these are just ones that
have stuck with me specifically if you
want to find this kind of thing on your
own my recommendation is to take a film
that is really good that you're familiar
with and watch it silently without any
sound when you do that the image and the
way cinematography is used pops out at
you in a way that it absolutely won't
otherwise a great film to do this with
would be Lee chongdong's Burning which
you know I've been hyping up endlessly
in these videos if you want to watch it
fortunately you can on mubi which is my
sponsor for this video Market
Moby is an online hand curated streaming
Cinema with an exceptional selection of
movies from all around the world they
really take their time to curate what's
on there and so it's not just a great
streaming service it's also a great way
to actually discover new interesting
things to watch it's kind of like having
your own personal Film Festival as a
streaming service so go launch burning
or just explore the library and I'm sure
you'll find something you're interested
in watching you can get a 30-day
extended free trial when you sign up
with my link by going to movie.com
thomasflight that's mubi.com
thomasflight or click the link on the
screen thanks again to mubi for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
foreign
[Music]